monsieur yao bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à l'heure
la brigade a donc été dissous des hommes
de la brigade vont être réaffectés
ailleurs le problème c'est la brigade où
les agents eux le problème des pense que
c'est à la fois les deux parce que est
tel qu'on a pu voir les images auraient
également des formations d'avoir subi
nigeria c'est légal et a complètement
dévié sa mission parce que ça me fait
penser à protéger les populations des
enfants aux populations donc tout à fait
normal que les jeunes qu'on le voit les
manifestations qui ont eu lieu notamment
oblige il aime également à londres ont
fini par avoir gain de cause
il fallait c'est vrai parce que je pense
que les autorités nigérianes n'avaient
pas le choix que les bisso dans la seine
les gars de jacques hopin dévié ses
missions alors d'un fonds de la police
au nigeria avait déjà été annoncée en
2017 en 2018 on sait que ça n'a jamais
abouti est ce que vous êtes optimiste
cette fois ci j'ai dit non parce que les
réformes on l'a attendu dans la loire
est vu au nigeria que ce soit vos larmes
et on a vu et même dans le combat car
beaucoup ont été faites mais le résultat
est quasi quoi mitigé et si l'art est de
même pour les forces de sécurité
notamment ces brigades qui dont la
mission est de lutter contre le grand
banditisme des braquages qui est c'est
vrai depuis début 2010 il ya eu des
réformes qui malheureusement nous ne
jamais plus aboutie et cela est ce qui
fait toute la difficulté qu on leur tour
les autorités nigérianes à pouvoir que
établi cette insécurité nous nous sommes
levés à l'intérieur mais également à
l'extérieur au travers des luttes anti
turques contre le glaucome ou quoi donc
moi j'y crois pas beaucoup et on attend
peut-être d'ici quelques mois on va voir
ce qu'ils soient là pour la donner est
ce que le fait d'avoir et 10 ouvre cette
bulgare va améliorer les conditions de
sécurité je dirais non
et parce que le 'triple a' s'opposent au
nouveau la formation parce que il suffit
pas de créer des brigades pour lutter
contre le grand banditisme les braquages
si ceux là mêmes qui sont chargés d donc
pas compris cette édition sont pas
formés comme si doigts et pense que
si un débat vu c'est parce que ses
agents n'ont pas été formés à la
déontologie du métier qui la police qui
consiste donc à protéger les biens et
les personnes
toute la question se pose là alors c'est
pour cela que la dissolution ou la
remise en cause 17 rue du gal mois ne
pourra pas mettre fin à cette insécurité
jolie julia alors certains parlent d'un
cas d'école en afrique et ce qu'il peut
s'agir là d'un tournant à ce que les
autres pays africains pourraient prendre
exemple sur ce qui s'est passé au
nigeria j'essaie que eu beaucoup de
soufre l'intervention des simples gadoue
et épique et écoles étatiques limin
alitée ou hunting grand banditisme et
c'est que dans cette épique sommes mal
en côte d'ivoire on a pu voir l'ensemble
les barbus et parfois semences la
population civile
et c'est que quand cette force
intervient génération était à
d'opération elle ne fait vraiment pas de
cadeaux parce que tu atterris vient
c'est pas pour arrêter les bandits ce
qu'on l'appelle pas dit où les abattre
alors et je pense que comme je l'aï dit
tantôt
mais toute la question se pose où au
niveau de la formation de ses forces
sipa de d'armes et des gens d appuyer
dans leur tenue qu'il faut et ces
personnes aillent sur le terrain pour
aller à commander des bandits et qui si
ces personnes sont pas bien formés titre
avait évidemment on va assister à des
telles bavures des pays de la sous
région
quoique il reprend les gia mais cela ne
suffit pas de sebring
tout doit se faire sur la base la
formation
voilà c'est tout cas base donc dès que
la formation fait que c'est les agents
qui sont chargés des missions on non
seulement les outils au niveau matériel
et outils au niveau physique nouveau
donc la mission qu'elle a signés et
pense que ces personnes pour accompli le
voilà ces gens les tâches on te voit
ainsi pas le cas de la france il ya eu
pas mal du fait qu'ils me donnent cette
ma réflexion
et voilà la police française et
notamment la bac
la brigade anticriminalité a eu un telle
issue et des opérations en aucun moment
et cette police sané pris à la
population civile pour moi même les
bandits souvent qu'ils sont puissamment
armés sont carrément de désarmer haut on
va dire neutraliser mais même mais pas
des gens qui sont abattus on le voit se
voir l'afrique mais c'est que tu as
souvent ici s'il savait que ces bandits
qui vont opérer une fois que son prix
ils sont attaqués à exécuter une façon
là voilà habiterait n'est pas dit que
voilà donc moi je suis en train
d'accuser est remis au nôtre mais c'est
que moi par le passé et j'ai pu assister
celle notamment en côte d'ivoire ou 7
des gars qui étaient vienne n'a jamais
fait de cadeau voilà donc c'est quoi que
même si ce n'est pas dit qu'on a on
appris hier où la sensibilité souvent
assez les quartiers souvent très peuplée
les gens ont du mal donc à amener ses
opérations mais il doit et quoique tour
s'est joué autour de la formation
monsieur yao merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et directeur de
publication du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui